so
it's a very short six second clip okay
i'm just gonna let it auto play as i
kind of talk over this
um they're at a gala event i don't know
where this is i'm assuming this is the
climate summit thing
um and uh you know leo's a big uh save
the whales guy you see pictures of him
on
the internet and social media with um uh
greta thundberg and you know all that
sort of stuff
he's also a very well-known player and
he's a great actor phenomenal actor in
fact i would i would put him right at
the top up there definitely in the top
five to 10 for sure
now
i think he's in his 40s if i'm not
mistaken 45 to 7 or so looks great for
his age has um has fame he has nowhere
near the kind of money that bezos has um
i can't keep track of bezos's wealth
because it's anywhere from 200 billion
to 400 billion depending on when he got
divorced or when you measure it or what
the stock value is and blah blah blah
the point being is
he is
one of the wealthiest men on the planet
uh i think elon musk is like number one
right now but they flip back and forth
depending on what their stock value is
he's loaded he's got more money than god
he can't spend it in his lifetime
he's going to give away a large portion
of it you know probably to charities and
stuff like that i mean he he'll he'll go
and spend some money on the world's
biggest yacht and still be you know the
world's richest man in the world you
know world sort of thing like you get
the idea you just can't spend that money
leo on the other hand
is a little younger a little better
looking has way more fame
um and in this clip over here you can
see lauren looking at him now i'm just
going to pause it when she gives him the
look um
right there you see this look over here
we've all seen that look okay not not
not all of us let's just say but a good
part of you guys out there have seen
this look from a woman before uh
i'm guessing she's probably had a few
drinks because she's kind of moving and
and behaving like somebody that's uh
you know a little uh on the happy side
if you know what i'm saying
okay
she's giving him that look he's not even
looking at her
which is which is hilarious um and you
know he's looking at bezos and beezus is
looking away but she's definitely given
him that look there like look at it
this is the come f me like you own me
look that's that's what that is if
you've never seen it that is genuine
desire and i'm going to talk about that
part of my chapter as well during this
cast kind of cover it shouldn't take me
too long there shouldn't be any more
than a 30 minute show but you get the
idea most dudes yeah like moths in the
chat most dudes never get this look okay
only guys that have seen genuine burning
desire you know a woman will get this
look now i'll be honest with you leo
wants nothing to do with her and i'll
show you why in a minute i mean he he's
uh he's got this uh track record of not
dating any woman that's over i think 28
or nine or seven or something like that
is a hard barrier but i'll show you that
um
you know i'll show you that uh
chart there uh somebody's asking if
bezos is really that short i don't think
he's
um short i think
leo is standing up on something because
if you watch here i think they both step
up onto a stage or something i'm not
sure
oh yeah so you can see right at the end
sanchez steps up onto something so it
looks like he's
walking up
because it looks like
she yeah she's definitely stepping up
onto something so i don't think he's
that short
but yeah you get the idea so this is
what genuine dirt burning desire looks
like it's unmistakable
um it was a good opportunity to um you
know basically just point it out that's
what it is if you're unfamiliar with it
and what it looks like he doesn't even
notice it like if you look at bezos
he actually looks away at the at the
point in time when she looks up to him
you see that
he's not even looking at her
anyway at least jeff's got a sense of
humor
because he he he put this out uh
the day after this is actually bezos's
uh twitter feed leo come over here i
want to show you something he tags them
and this is dangerous steep cliff fatal
drop and you've got bezos sitting over
here on a sign i don't know where he is
looks like somewhere tropical
looking all saucy sauced out with his
jack traps and shoulders you know this
guy's on therapeutic testosterone he's
been on it for a while uh he's
definitely looks max he's not a
you know he's not a 10 when it comes to
trying to compete with b with um
dicaprio but he's got bank like he's got
serious bank and that just goes to show
you know when it comes to the argument
of um
what is it the argument that all these
uh doomers guys uh use you know looks
versus money versus status versus game
versus blah blah blah ideally you want
as much of all of it as you can possibly
get for yourself personally and if you
want to do well with women but um
as far as the uh argument between
whether or not
uh money or looks and fame because
status is kind of tied into fame i mean
it is tied into fame but
whether it's money or fame and looks
uh clearly leonardo dicaprio won on that
duel there's no question
definitely one out in that duel and
people are in the chat right nice now
saying you know
um bezos needs to dump her i'm going to
tell you at the end what i think
um of this scenario and how bezos should
probably handle something like this
um
but that's how
jeff responded to it
at least you got to give the guy some
credit he's got a sense of humor when he
tries to you know make something out of
it although
i don't know this way that i would have
done it um i certainly have never dealt
with a scenario where a chick i'm with
looks at another guy like that it's it's
it's really bizarre but you get the idea
anyway um
so let's take this out i can close that
clip
so the people involved so let's take a
look at who who lauren sanchez is
where is she there we go there's a
wikipedia page let's throw that up
hi lauren add the stream um so personal
life sanchez
born in nineteen so so
she's old
she's in her fifties uh personal life
sanchez has a son nico
in 2001 from formal nfl tight end tony
gonzalez also i'm pronouncing that
completely wrong
and then a few years later so this is uh
this is a unwed
bastard child i guess i don't know
whatever you want to call it and then
she married this dude uh patrick weissel
who's a hollywood agent founding partner
of endeavor she has a son and a daughter
so she's a single mom of three kids
bezos the world's richest man
linked up
left his marriage in fact because
she because she divorced uh this guy uh
white cell in 2019 which is the same
time bezos left his wife
um they were allegedly um
having an affair i don't know who cares
whatever but um she left her husband and
uh bezos left his wife mackenzie bezos
around that time and they linked up
why bezos went for
a post-wall single mom of three kids who
was a clear life monkey brancher i mean
she's done nothing with her life
honestly i mean she's uh i mean okay i'm
probably being a little bit too hard on
her she's she's a
sealist sort of actor i mean everything
that she's acted in she's basically
acted as herself which is a newscaster
broadcaster news reporter tv anchor
uh fox news reporter reporter reporter
herself blah blah blah so she's only
acted in roles where
she's basically behaved in what she does
for her life she's never done anything
outside of that and they're and they're
just um small cameos nothing that's you
know like a significant role obviously
same thing with television credits looks
like anchor woman news anchor news
anchor and blah blah blah she's really
done nothing of any significance bezos
is a god compared to her and she
definitely
she basically got herself a pretty good
deal i mean hypergamy financially he's
been satisfied you know she's got her
alpha seed from the nfl tight end
and a couple more from a hollywood agent
and then she linked up with bezos
uh in her 50s she's post wall probably
menopausal postmenopausal who knows who
cares doesn't matter the point being is
bezos could probably pick from a far
better pool of you know women when it
comes to stuff like this so that's
that's that's one part of the equation
that's the her part um i did a little
bit of googling on her and i came across
um a few articles
uh bezos's girlfriend lauren chance
sanchez she was pretty uh she was a
smoke show in her younger days this is a
picture of her i think it says here 18
19 years old at the time this is her on
the far left
uh she's a unit you know all natural you
know back in the day where women didn't
have tattoos and purple hair and um you
know much much cosmetic work but she's
done a lot of cosmetic work since then
she's definitely had work done on her
face she's had a lift done on you know
what gravity's done and childbirth has
done to the ladies
um you guys can you know get the idea
over there but i mean for her age she's
a good-looking woman you know let's just
say that you know we can say that at
least um
let's go to leonardo dicaprio
and where's this chart chart chart chart
there it is
uh let's just pinch and zoom this a
little bit bigger
so it fills the screen and some of you
have probably seen this maybe some of
you haven't um it's relevant because
somebody i can't believe somebody
actually put this together
but there it is this is a leonardo
dicaprio refuses to date women his age
range chart
he gets older they stay the same age
leo's 45 plus now he's probably late 40s
i'm going to say 47 48 49 he's probably
close to same age as me
and constantly dates women in
less than 25 so the age
limit actually no sorry it's not even 27
it's 25 this is the max age limit that
dicaprio dates in
they're all models
or they all look like models all fair
light-haired blonde haired blue eyes
sort of chicks
he is spoiled for choice when it comes
to women doesn't matter what his age is
the cap always stays the same
so
does bezos have any risk of uh
you know uh dicaprio stealing his
girlfriend from him no
it's not it's it's not his game somebody
else might
you know that that might be into um you
know older women but not leo he he's
he's i mean his track record clearly
shows that he's not interested he's a
player you know he's
you know it's funny because he's like
this left-wing hollywood guy but he's
also unplugged in the sense that he that
he's not going to get married or i've
never seen him ever talk about wanting
to do it in fact um
i think him and his buddy clooney
um you know at one point they were
they were both mentioned as uh bachelors
and uh why don't they act their own age
and date women their own age and blah
blah i think clooney ended up folding
and marrying this um
again you know older uh lawyer and um
dicaprio still stayed single and he's
still enjoying his life without any risk
of any problems that some of the things
that clooney's starting to deal with now
in fact i think he's been started to be
quite public about it
anyway you got to give leo credit
the guy's living mental point of origin
i don't agree with all the lefty
hollywood bs that he's doing
but as far as mental point of origin
putting himself first
and um you know essentially like he is
the apex alpha god sort of guy now
where
he can he can date pretty much any woman
he wants in any age category he wants
bezos could probably do the same from
being honest he needs a little more
unplugging why he settled for a single
mom of three that's a clear monkey
brancher uh looking for financial
resources it's it's absolutely clear i
mean you know you can't deny that that's
why she's with him if he was broke if he
was a
garbage collector a guy that had like a
blue collar sort of 60 000 a year job
she wouldn't even look his way clearly
so
let's all dive into um let's remove that
from the screen actually i've already
taken it out from your screen mine's
still here
there's the chart let me take those out
we've dealt with the sanchez thing you
already know who bezos is so it doesn't
require any further clarification let me
see if i can get this uh pdf up on the
screen of this chapter from my book
uh to do
let's see here stop share share
window pdf
share
okay there we go
so this is just a
a pdf review copy that i've that i that
i sent out when i released the book to a
few people in advance before it got uh
posted on amazon if you don't have the
book by the way
um
you can find it on amazon it's always
pinned below in the
top comments of all my videos uh it's
called the unplugged alpha kindle print
and audible um it's 10 bucks get it i
mean if if you want to get some clarity
on what's going on
in the world today when it comes to
success in women it's it's a it's a must
read it's it's done well it's full five
stars out there anyway um so there's a
chapter in my book on why genuine
burning desire matters i'm going to skip
over most of it um
there's an area where i help define what
what it looks like and how to gauge it
and there's three levels of interest
that you need to get some clarity on
there's genuine burning desire which is
a top scorer nine to ten if we're being
honest the look sanchez gave dicaprio is
definitely a 10. if there could be 11 or
17 on the scale i would say it's a 17
out of 10 but it's capped at 10 this is
a definite hard ten she's looking at the
dude like come f me like you own me sort
of thing like that is that is a look
that that dicaprio got in front of her
boyfriend jeff bezos not a good thing
but it is what it is uh again bezos
doesn't have anything to worry about
because leo doesn't roll with um that
kind of uh woman obviously and you can
tell by his body language when you know
when they're talking you know he's
basically walking away like i'm really
not interested i kind of want to you
know he's actually trying to exit the
conversation he probably felt
uncomfortable wanting to walk away from
what i understand bezos and dicaprio are
actually friends um it just wasn't a
random social encounter at a gala event
anyway
so a score of nine to ten are promoters
that's genuine desire seven and eights
are a different type of women meaning uh
nothing good or bad to say about you
they're they're they're more or less
weighing you as like a backup plan if
anything you're going to be beta bucks
in a hypergamy equation she's not your
fir she's not looking at you like her
first choice and then a lower score
somewhere between one and six are
detractors these women just don't care
they just if you were on fire and she
had a glass of water in her hand she
would just drink it and walk it away she
wouldn't splash it on you nothing you
would not get her attention she did like
you're invisible basically to women if
she doesn't have anything close to
indifference or promotion for desire for
you it's considered detraction is what
it is and all that's explained in the
chapter um let me just spell out what
genuine burning desire looks like in the
top score
when a woman truly desires you and i'm
just going to read this you know
straight off the chapter in the book
when a woman truly desires you you'll
know it she'll show up on time she'll
call or text you without making the
first attempt she'll also respond
quickly willingly enter your frame and
compliment your life without wanting to
be the focus of it she'll also ask you
questions to get you know better
this this is the general first step when
it comes to like dating apps or your
messaging back and forth she's going to
openly ask you questions there like what
do you do for a living where do you live
uh that picture of you with the data you
know what were you guys doing there
stuff like that you get the idea
she may also buy you random gifts make
you meals and follow you closely on
social media she'll even message you
first on a dating app always responding
quickly she'll show up for dates with
makeup and nice clothes she'll
enthusiastically f your brains have your
brains out
you get the idea uh she'll often also
initiate intimacy with you unprovoked
when a woman genuinely desires you it'll
be obvious as taking a blow from a
frying pan to the forehead in case you
didn't see it that's basically what
leonardo
felt
when she gave him that look that's what
that is
you